it's time once again for our monthly
meetup to run through the PS plus
offerings this time it's January 2019
and we have six games to download three
of which are available on your ps4
there's a few extras you should be aware
of too this month
especially if you're a warframe or
Fortnight player let's start with the
headliners on the ps4 first up is steep
steep is set in an open world snowy
valley with 4 unique ways to traverse
skiing snowboarding paragliding and the
most terrifying evolve wingsuit jumping
the emphasis of steep is exploring the
mountain unlocking new challenges to
complete mastering tricks is a great
deal of fun and snowboarding challenges
particularly feel like cool boarders if
you've ever played that series your
character can be customized and allows
your avatar to stand out from other
players in the server oh yeah by the way
it's an online game the main issue I
found with steep is how quickly it can
become a little too repetitive and if
you don't like one of the spots on offer
the content can wear thin for me
I dislike paragliding but I adored
snowboarding as this is a sandbox of
snow box rather the random games you and
a friend come up with will give steep
longevity the last time I'd played with
my mate James we spent hours attempting
to see who could ragdoll down a mountain
the farthest I'll link a video now just
in case you want to see that random
random rubbish as a UV sub game we can
rest assured that continual improvements
have been made and will continue to be
implemented in future months the review
scars mirror my personal feelings with
scars ranging from six out of ten from
Destructoid to a whopping 8.5 from game
informer only one way to know if it's
your type of game get it downloaded On
January 1st the second game on the ps4
is portal kings from the outset we can
see the Minecraft influences portal
Nights combines those building and
exploring aspects of Minecraft with the
addition of action RPG elements for
example combat is third-person with our
character able to lock on to enemies the
RPG portion allows players to choose
classes assigned talents and level up
boss battles unique dungeons they're all
here in fact I remember an interview
where the dev described portal Nights as
minecraft
with Diablo online play is also
supported allowing you and three more
friends to inhabit the same world the
console version released in May 2017
with a Metacritic score of 71 out of a
hundred at present someone give us a
nudge in the right direction should we
try this over to the ps3 and the Zoe
series or to give it the official title
zone of the enders HD collection set in
the 22nd century when mankind have
ventured across space mechs
are used for both labor and military
combats the story revolves around the
latter of those two with a super weapon
that could destroy the universe if
you're into mechs this is a great use of
your time and includes previous games
the final game in particular zone of the
enders the second Runner is said to be
the best in the series reviewing at 82
out of 100 right I'm going to quickly go
over the PS plus extras now because the
games from this point aren't too
impressive
first up fortnight players there's
another character skin you can download
with a back fling - he looks like
Skrillex at Christmas Worf Ramos if you
don't know already there's booster pack
3 available for you guys right now
there's 100 platinum amongst other
things to grab more PS plus freebies for
other games include Warface and trials
fusion but for me it's all about this
guy and his calculator back bling next
on the ps3 is amplitude this is a rhythm
game from before Guitar Hero and beat
Sabre controlling a ship you will build
every track of a song memorizing beats
timing and note combinations the music
is almost exclusively electronic dance
tracks so if you think that's just noise
you might want to avoid this one but if
you want to relive one of the defining
moments in rhythm game history grab it
over on the Vita now and the first game
is also downloadable on your ps4 this is
fallen Legion flames of rebellion
described as an intense action RPG with
heart-pounding impact and realism I
think they're over selling that I've
only tried it for about an hour or two
so my opinion may not be up to scratch
here what I remember vividly are the
load times and the janky frame rate when
numerous characters were on screen at
the same time on the plus side the
narrative is voiced and the combat is
fun current metacritic score four point
two out of ten finally super mutant
alien assault you are one of the last
surviving humans pursued by mutant
aliens
essentially this is an arcade shooter
with a few platforming elements
it supports two-player cooperative play
- getting it I love to know your
thoughts okay so I know what you
thinking this month isn't cracking I
agree it isn't great but hopefully we
all have a few games left over from
Christmas to play personally I'm gonna
dive headfirst into steep again after
taking a break of almost two years maybe
I'll see you there
what about you what are you grabbing
this month I imagine from PlayStation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]